قالت فاطمه سمراء مدينه العامه الاتحاد
الدولي لكره القدم ان انظار العالم ستتجه
نوع وقطر في العشرين من الشهر الجاري مع
انطلاق كاس العالم بحفل افتتاح وصفته بانه
سيكون الاجمل على الاطلاق كما اتنت سمره
على كرم الضيافه القطريه الذي يتمتع به
الشعب القطري موضحه في الوقت ذاته استعداد
قطر لاستقبال العالم في ظروف مميزه
لمتابعتي
نوفمبر
العالم كله سبق قطر التي ستشهد مهرجان
كرويا بالاحتفالات ايا كان عرقك ودينك
وتوجهك فانت مرحب بك والقطر يونس سعدون
لاستقبلك بافضل ضيافه يمكنك تخيلها حفل
الافتتاح سيكون الحدث رياضيا اكثر اظهارا
على الاطلاق عليك فقط ان تتذكر ان تجلس
على مقاعدك قبل ساعه الخامسه والنصف مساء
تشاهد اجمل حفل على الاطلاق